the thing is with Osama he was in a
hurry to marry me
the second time I went to Morocco and
then this time he wants to like slow
down it's like hey what happened before
me and David gets married I need some
time to know each other more in reality
I start to feel
I gained 20 pounds maybe he thinks
thinks that and then you know I started
thinking well what did I do something
wrong I said I thought you know all my
intentions were Noble minded and then I
said to myself maybe he's got a young
girlfriend and if he does let me know
because I let you go in a heartbeat I
want you to be happy you know I'm not
some lecherous old lady looking to sink
my claws into him he said I want you to
be happy and good in life that's all I
want and yeah if you're my husband we
could accomplish a lot together
but it's like if not if I'm not your cup
of tea hey I'm not gonna Force you yeah
yeah it's so interesting because people
compare you to Angela
another 90 day cast member but you are
nothing alike clearly but how do you
feel about those comparisons it's
strange when they compare me to her
because I consider myself it's not that
I'm an elitist it's just that
I have the ideals I have much more high
ideals I'm not interested in somebody if
they they can you know give me good sex
and that's all about you know I'm all
about ideas and goals and plans to
elevate ourselves in humanity and I
think uh she's not that way but you know
who's to say I hope she becomes that way
but it's like I think she's so
distracted about instant pleasure you
know pleasure doesn't come
instantaneously it takes time you build
up on it and you make something you make
something you can be proud of and hold
your head up high and I think maybe
Angela's still learning that
I'm about to step into my whole new life
now Morocco is my home it's Osama come
on
he looks handsome where we are in the
season right now you are just leaving to
go be with Osama I'm curious do you plan
to work while you're over there I know
you have this beautiful piece that you
made on your neck do you plan to do your
artwork over there and make money yes I
plan to open an art studio with open mic
night and I want to attract the local
artists and people that are suffering
because they don't have an opportunity
for their creative gifts and so I would
do some type of forum I plan to still
make jewelry and the art studio and it
would be just a wonderful Pleasant thing
where artists could hang out and plus
those people that never have an
opportunity it's like this is my mission
is to help those people that suffer
because they can't fit in and it's like
okay bring me the iris bring me your
depressed bring me the people that need
some guidance and mentoring it's like
I'm there I'm that's my job as a human
being wow I love so is this how when did
you find that this is this is your
purpose when did you discover that or
get clear on it it started out as a
little light and then it got bigger and
bigger because then I said GW you're not
the only person in the world that has
suffered and went through a lot of bad
things and bad childhood abuse and all
that stuff I said there's lots of people
did you know that every day just in the
United States over 5 000 middle
schoolers and high schoolers try to
commit suicide every single day and you
know all this stuff starts adding up to
me it's like Debbie you have to do your
part you have to be the hand there was
no hand for me but by gosh I'm gonna I'm
gonna do something you know at my age
I'm only thing I can leave behind is
kindness and for someone else to pick up
the torch after me and that that's all
that counts you know it's not the money
the bank account where when or why it's
like let me start simple and let
kindness lead the way
I love that Debbie it sounds like you
plan to live in Morocco forever you're
building a business over there and is
that is that what you're planning yes
I'm planning to live there forever and
down the road you know who's to say you
know if everything works wonderfully I
could keep two homes one in the United
States one in Morocco but uh right now
I'm just going to concentrate on living
in Morocco and coming back and picking
up some more of my artwork and art
supplies and bringing them to Morocco
visiting the kids making sure to calm
down to kids let's let's you know that
would be an uprising but you know it's
like let me live my life you mentioned
your kids calming them down Julian's
plea for you not to leave at the airport
was heartbreaking I'm scared you won't
get hurt I'm scared of something bad
might happen nothing bad's gonna happen
I want you to be happy for me I mean
in a different situation I've been super
ecstatic for you but it just to me
doesn't add up right
he's young mom somebody stole our mom
from us Looking Back Now
how do you feel just reflecting on that
moment of him begging you not to go
you know that's my my biggest uh
obstacle is my heart is here with my son
and my daughter and uh they have loved
me so much they have been my best
friends and my kids I mean it doesn't
get any better than that my relationship
with my children and they turned out
fine even though it's like
I didn't have a lot of good skills but
love covers everything love and positive
reinforcement and encouragement and yeah
you know a part of me is always going to
beat myself up it's like hey Debbie
why'd you leave your kids Behind they
love you so much but then I think well
maybe and then I have these Visions
Grandeur well maybe you know I can bring
Sandy over and she can come work the art
studio sometimes and then Julian maybe
even though he's not an artist he could
come and just check it out and maybe try
to Mentor some young men or some you
know who knows where it could lead to
okay well what can you tease about
what's in store for you and Osama for
the rest of the season
well I'm just so excited about Osama and
his parents and it's like you know he
reassures me that they're gonna accept
me and love me and that brings me great
comfort because who wants to go meet
your future mother-in-law and
father-in-law and they happen to be
right around your same age I mean that's
scary and it's like you know I'd rather
poke my eye out with the stick than have
to go over there and say hey look I'm in
love with your 24 year old son and we
have plans and I'm moving here you know
who who looks forward to that but his
sister is endearing and kind and she's
like accepting me and I just hang on to
that like okay I'm not mean and they're
gonna see me and they're gonna know that
I only have good intentions for their
son to to lift him up you know not to
drag him down or to say hey you're my
husband
Debbie doesn't
operate